I'm still very bullish on bitcoin
Bitcoin is the only asset right now
which looks interesting to me there's a
limited Supply which is very important
cuz the reason that we're in this mess
right now is cuz they were printing
endless amounts of money so that's
really important I look at history so
the last bull market we saw a correction
of 80% so if I was to use that and
predict what the bottom of this Market
could be it would come down to around
$13,600 however globally things are a
massive mess right now there's still a
war going on in Europe with Russia and
Ukraine we're seeing endless amounts of
money still being printed we now have an
energy crisis which means that things
are very bad basically inflation is
going crazy so I would expect more black
one events to potentially bring Bitcoin
even lower maybe around $10,000 but
these are amazing buying opportunities